[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et vous êtes vous retrouvée pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres
nicolas hulot était dans les yvelines
hier le ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire a visité l'inra
et là notamment découvert les travaux
sur la biomasse menée par l'institut
notre portrait de la semaine est dédiée
a émis cette chanteuse à la voix d'or
originaire de bois d'arcy ne vous
laissera pas indifférent
derrière ses longs cheveux blonds se
cache une battante atteinte d'une
maladie orpheline et puis direction la
micro ferme de gally où vous apprendrez
toutes les astuces pour faire pousser
vos fruits et légumes une activité
ludique pour embellir son jardin ou sont
otages et on débute ce journal avec
cette info 92 79 % de réussite au
baccalauréat général des yvelines se
classe en tête dans l'académie de
versailles pour les résultats 2010 est
il en est de même pour le baccalauréat
professionnel avec 78,94 % des reçus
paris a passé son grand oral aujourd'hui
à lausanne en suisse pour les jo de 2024
face aussi aux la capitale tentaient
d'obtenir son ticket face à los angeles
cette journée s'est terminée par un vote
du cio et sans grande surprise ils ont
voté la double attribution des jo-2000
24 et 2028
dès le 13 septembre à lima à paris aura
donc des jeux une aubaine pour saint
quentin en yvelines plusieurs
compétitions auront lieu sur le
territoire on passe à la politique
nicolas hulot s'est rendu dans les
yvelines hier le ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire était
à l'inra de versailles
retour sur cette visite avec patrick
jacques de dixmude et charline hurel
une agriculture durable c'est ce que
nicolas hulot ministre de la transition
écologique et le ministre de
l'agriculture stéphane travert sont
venus découvrir à l'inra de versailles
dans ce laboratoire
emmanuel jacquin joly directrice de
recherche met au point une stratégie de
biocontrôle sur les insectes et leur
odorat
nous étudions l'odorat des insectes et
le goût des insectes donc leur sens
chimique pour essayer de mieux
comprendre comment ça fonctionne pour
finalement mettre au point des méthodes
qui vont les leurs et les perturbés dans
leur communication chimique et donc à la
base de nouvelles méthodes de mieux
contrôler donc on peut faire des pièges
par exemple des pièges avec ce type
d'odeur on peut aussi faire de la
confusion peut mettre un petit peu
d'odeurs partout comme ça ils savent
plus trop y sent une méthode qui
permettrait d'éviter l'utilisation de
pesticides évoqué par nicolas hulot il y
a quelques semaines
une annonce qui avait provoqué un couac
avec son homologue de l'agriculture
cette visite se voulait aussi une
manière de prouver que les deux
ministres travaillent qu'ensemble nous
poursuivons le même objectif c'est que
demain nos modèles agricoles
quel qu'il soit puisse trouver des
débouchés les débouchés commerciaux
bien évidemment que les agriculteurs et
c'est le leitmotiv sur lequel je
travaille puissent vivre dignement de
leur métier
ce dont nous avons besoin c'est de
compléter notre approche
il ya une fenêtre d'opportunité pour
faire prendre modèle alimentaire au
modèle agricole un virage non pas à 180°
non pas en jetant tout l'existant mais
voilà en tenant compte des paramètres
paramètres climatiques de la demande des
consommateurs
l'ambition de souveraineté alimentaire
de la france on sortira ensemble par le
haut ou pas mais il y en a pas un qui
sera gagnant parce qu'on partage la même
ambition immunité qui devrait se
concrétiser fin juillet avec les états
généraux de l'alimentation
un événement pour proposer des solutions
autour de la répartition des produits
alimentaires et sur le lien entre
alimentation et environnement l'été est
synonyme de soleil et de vacances mais
pas que c'est aussi le moment propice
zibeline d'intensifier ses travaux
entretien des routes faciliter l'accès
entre les villes l'objectif pour le
département améliorer les conditions de
circulation des yvelinois mais manier
poker rénovation renforcement de la
chaussée ou encore aménagement des
routes
les travaux des dés sont lancés dans les
yvelines sur les 1600 km de routes pas
moins de 70 chantiers sont prévus dans
68 communes
l'objectif pour le département assurer
le bon état des routes et prévenir les
risques d'accidents dans ses travaux
d'été on trouve différents types de
travaux donc des travaux d'aménagement
de circulations douces comme ce qu'on
voit ici sur la piste cyclable bucs tous
eu des travaux d'aménagement de sécurité
routière donc ça peut être des travaux
d'aménagement de carrefour actifs
ication de carrefour création d'un
giratoire voit la reprise de virages
enfin tout ce qui est lié à la sécurité
routière aux déplacements des usagers
chaque année l'entretien des voiries et
travaux coûtent 10 millions d'euros et
le département n'a pas choisi la période
estivale par hasard - de circulation des
températures idéales mais surtout moins
de gêne pour les usagers
certaines routes seront fermées ou en
circulation alternée
la sécurité routière c'est fondamental
quand il y à des zones dites
accidentogène on essaye de les résorber
on ne le fait pas seul on le fait en
partenariat bien évidemment avec les
communes parce que vous imaginez bien
que si vous intervenez dans un axe au
coeur d'une ville il faut quand même on
le prépare ensemble et le financement
est partagé avec la région parce qu'il y
à des programmes justement de sécurité
des travaux d'été qui ne devrait durer
que quelques semaines
mais parmi les grands chantiers celui de
la rd30 qui entre dans sa dernière phase
et devrait se terminer prochainement
notre portrait d'aujourd'hui dédié a
émis cette chanteuse originaire de bois
d'arcy à la boîte d'or ne vous laissera
pas de marbre
derrière ces noms cheveux blonds se
cache une battante attente d'une maladie
orpheline elle nous livre son combat
nicolas quere l'oit et coups de blues
elle dit que la musique l'a sauvée alors
qu'elle n'était encore qu'une
adolescente et mis 19 ans est
aujourd'hui une chanteuse indépendante
qui a su se faire connaître à la voix
douce et touchante et au parcours
incroyable mars 1998
emilie de son vrai prénom n'est atteint
d'une maladie génétique rare s'empaler
et malentendantes une maladie presque
invisible jusqu'à ses 14 ans est alors
une enfant comme les autres qui aiment
sourire aux caractères bien prononcé
tout bascule à l'adolescence l'âge où
les jeunes adultes se chercher les mots
deviennent blessant quand j'étais plus
jeune on primaires c'était des petits
insultes ou d'enfants en gardant tout ce
qui va avec ne s'était pas encore
violent comme les adolescents
après ce qui a été le plus violent pour
moi ça a été une crachats mais je suis
cracher dessus avant l'arrivée au
collège et ça c'est quelque chose que je
n'oublierai jamais jugé moquée et me
traverse alors des années compliquer la
vie de famille s'en trouve parfois
chamboulé heureusement pour elle l'amour
des plus proches résisté notamment les
amitiés
car là c'est une amie d'enfance qui
j'étais en primaire taillage stéphanie
qui est là aussi et là y'a mélanie c'est
ma meilleure amie
c'est des années qui ont été là vraiment
dans les pires années comme dans les
meilleures années n'ont jamais lâché
n'ont jamais juger donc pour moi c'est
comme une famille d'ailleurs si les
seules photos que j'ai dans ma chance et
je pense que c'est important de garder
ça actuellement et à côté d'elle ses
meilleurs amis le sont aussi dans sa
carrière de chanteuse
musique est un destin qui amy a su se
forger à 17 ans presque tout seul dans
sa chambre
des vidéos postées sur internet la
rencontre avec l'auteur boris bergman et
un premier single enregistré en 2016
[Musique]
nous sert de lutter pour
mais ce besoin de tout bois
gachet
vis ma vie
comme depuis le succès d'amy se confirme
dix mille fans sur facebook et instagram
la jeune bachelière souhaite à travers
son parcours porter un message d'espoir
oui c'est dur chez c'est dur mais vous
n'êtes pas enfin vous êtes pas moins
qu'un doute en fait il n'y a personne tu
la personne en dessous on est tous
capables on a tous des capacités et
c'est pas sûr qu'on est malade qu'on a
pu ses capacités mais le problème des
gens c'est que les gens vont vous font
croire ça et à force
à force de vous y croyez au fait et si
ça c'est ça il faut pas tomber dans le
piège en septembre et mis débutera un
bts en alternance elle sortira bientôt
également un premier en europe et
symbole d'un équilibre retrouvé qu'elle
souhaite partager ce statut
je fonce en tout
le secours populaire propose plusieurs
dispositifs dans les yvelines pour
permettre à des personnes dans le besoin
de partir en vacances
reportage de nicolas landry et mathilde
en skate à la 5 ans et blanches 8 ans
vont passer une partie des vacances
d'été ensemble elles sont déjà copine
une complicité née de leur rencontre
c'est quand j'ai vu les chiens et
qu'elle avait peur des chiens et bien
fraîche à l'affairé une centaine
d'enfants une vingtaine de familles vont
bénéficier comme à la des dispositifs
proposés par le secours populaire
objectif permettre aux plus précaires de
partir en vacances
en fait le constat c'est qu'il ya
toujours un français sur trois qui part
pas en vacances donc nous à notre niveau
on prétend pas résoudre le problème du
non départ mais au moins manifester
notre solidarité en premier vis-à-vis
des familles que l'on connaît par le
biais des réseaux des permanences
d'accueil jusqu'au peu claires sur
département sophie gré elle s'est
inscrite au dispositif copains des
vacances elle va accueillir à la pendant
deux semaines avec un programme déjà
bien remplie dès mercredi après demain
nous allons prendre le train pour
descendre chez mes beaux parents qui
habitent dans le sud de la france
on va rester là bas une semaine après on
va rentrer chez nous du côté de
rambouillet là on habite à la campagne
et puis on va être à la maison faire des
activités de promenade en forêt
ça fait plaisir pour des enfants pour
aller en vacances avec sa copine et moi
je dis c'est avec ce qu'on pouvait dire
c'est que l'on parle de la mer le 20
juillet encore avec la petite famille
pour passer et c'est le moment des au
revoir la fille de jama part avec sa
nouvelle copine direction sa maison à la
boissière l'école pour retrouver les
chiens de blanche reconnecter l'urbain
au jardin c'est l'objectif du nouvel
espace de la ferme de gally une micro
ferme dans la pépinière du magasin pour
découvrir de nouvelles techniques pour
son potager ou même son balcon
elle est accessible à tous et tous les
jours nous sommes allés la découvrir
avec charline hurel
[Musique]
véritable jardin d'éden au coeur de la
ferme de gally potager ruche et
poulaillers une micro ferme pédagogique
pour favoriser le lien entre ville et
nature
c'est une sensibilité des gens très
largement à l'agriculture urbaine ou au
final les particuliers peuvent jouer un
rôle dans cette agriculture et en fait
chacun est en mesure de de produire ses
propres fruits et légumes sur son balcon
sont 1 terrasse ou son jardin ont fait
germer une petite graine dans la tête
des gens que c'est possible de produire
des fruits et légumes en ville une
grande fleur dessiné au sol regroupe les
différentes techniques à découvrir
spirale de plantes aromatiques culture
en lasagnes ou paillage chaque pétale a
sa spécialité
mais pour les plus petits espaces c'est
derrière qu'il faut regarder une tour d'
pommes de terre à réaliser chez soi même
sur un balcon
on a effectué une première couche de
terreau dans lequel dans laquelle on a
planté nos pommes de terre ensuite les
pommes de terre ont germé elles ont
commencé à pousser au fur et à mesure
que la plante pousse à on a rajouté des
couches de terreau elles sont montées
jusqu'ici voilà on va s'arrêter là on va
laisser la plante pousser encore un
petit peu et les pommes de terre pour
apparaître sur toute la hauteur de la
structure
un dernier pétales sera créée autour des
plantes mellifères qui fleurissent en
automne et en hiver
lorenzo aura besoin d'être cet été pour
le réaliser chacun est invité à mettre
la main à la pâte ou plutôt à la terre
c'est la fin de 7,8 le journal merci de
nous avoir suivis et bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]